flow Arts is about to explode those were
the words my friend Charlie said to me
back in 2012 and he wasn't the only one
who thought that in the span of a decade
flow and fire Arts had gone from a
deeply underground curiosity to
exploding in popularity with a growing
community of artists all over the world
we were on the news in music videos TV
shows America's Got Talent it seemed
like flow of fire and POI spinning were
right on the precipice of becoming a
mainstream art and yeah it's 2023 now
and that clearly didn't happen
but why hi my name is Drex and I make
videos about POI spinning and flow Arts
to benefit your body and brain and I
want to take a deep dive into the
history of the flow Arts why did we seem
so certain that we were about to blow up
and why did it never materialize real
quick please make sure to support the
channel and leave me a like And
subscribe to understand why it seems so
weird to me that flow Arts didn't go
mainstream it's important to understand
why we were so sure that it was so let's
take a look at what had come in the
decade leading up to that conversation
between Charlie and I the origins of the
modern flow and fire Arts scene remain a
little bit obscure but I think it's safe
to say that they were the product of
several other different threads all
coming together in the late 1990s the
Rave and EDM scene had gone from
underground subculture to mainstream
awareness and was about to explode into
a massive industry in its own right
along with this came more exposure for
Rave conventions like close stringing
and hula hooping gateways through which
many people picked up a prop for the
first time fire dancing had become a
common fixture at Polynesian themed
performance venues and had also caught
on amongst buskers Backpacker culture
and Sideshow performers in addition
Burning Man had hit a critical
inflection point and had gone from Bay
Area curiosity to mainstream shorthand
for modern American counterculture
Burning Man was also a Melting Pot of
different artistic and performance
genres that were then dispersed all over
the world and finally Cirque Nouveau had
reinvigorated the circus genre and
become massively popular in Europe with
circus festivals drawing in large crowds
and juggling clubs at colleges and
universities churning out large numbers
of young people with a fondness for prop
manipulation and skill toys these Trends
came to a head in 2004 with the founding
of fire drums the first fire and flow
Festival in the world and this is really
important for a few reasons first it
made explicit that flow and fire Arts
were a unique subculture unto themselves
rather than being a smaller part of
other bigger scenes there was now a
culture with its own values expectations
and needs that could only be partially
met at other events having an event
catered specifically to us meant that we
had specific needs and therefore were
our own thing second it created a
template that nearly all flow-based
events have followed ever since a hybrid
of trade show convention music festival
and Regional burn the model fire drums
came up with survives more or less
intact to the present day and has been
adopted by countless other events since
finally it created a specific venue in
which accomplished artists in this
emerging world were able to come
together and exchange ideas rapidly
growing the potential of the art and the
vocabulary around it to this day the
fire and flow festivals also function as
incubators of ideas and Innovation
around flow and the idea exploded people
raced to copy or create their own
remixes of the model all over the
country and all over the world too we
went from a small handful of events in
2007 when I entered the flow Arts world
to more than 50 of them by 2012. you
could just about go to an event every
single weekend of the year and this
explosion and interest coincided with
the launch of YouTube and Instagram as
content sharing platforms making it
easier than ever to introduce people to
the flow arts and more importantly how
to do it freestyle firepoi became the
first POI video to make it to more than
a million views and a whole generation
of flow stars were minted through online
video including yours truly we began
seeing fire and flow popping up in
popular TV shows music videos America's
Got Talent the list goes on and on and
there was an explosion in the number of
businesses being founded that built prop
specifically catered to flow artists
when I entered this world a lot of us
really had to make our own props within
a year or two though professional
quality LED and fire props began to
become really commonplace Charlie and
many others compared flow Arts to where
snowboarding was in the 1980s primed to
explode into pop culture relevance this
was about the time that I made the
decision to quit my non-profit job here
in DC and just do POI full-time I
remember telling friends and colleagues
when I quit that the reason was that I
felt like I was standing on the stage at
CBGB in 1976 and that everything felt
like it was about to change POI Flo and
fire were going to be the next big thing
and what happened next was
well
we didn't it's 2023 and if you stop a
random person on the street they'll
probably have no idea what POI flow arts
or fire spinning are and I don't think
that this is a bad metric to go by just
about any Rando I pull off the street
regardless of whether they do them or
not is probably familiar with
skateboarding snowboarding heck probably
Burning Man in Cirque du Soleil 2 for
that matter so what happened and is
there any chance that we still could go
mainstream short answer I think there
were a lot more barriers to entry than
we realized both in terms of
accessibility and culture and yes I
think there's still a chance that we can
go mainstream but it's going to require
some pretty major changes so let's start
off by talking about accessibility as I
see it there are really three components
to accessibility the first is how people
get introduced to the thing that is how
is it that they learn that it exists and
want to do the thing the second is the
initial barriers to entry and the final
one is churn rate how do you keep people
engaged in the thing over time if we're
talking about getting introduced to the
thing we absolutely have to talk about
fire which has been both a benefit and a
curse to the flow Arts nearly everyone I
know that got into flow near the same
time I did all did so for the exact same
reason to learn to spend fire spinning
unlit tools was just practice for the
fire and that was considered the highest
expression of flow and fire makes for a
great hook it's impressive to watch
activate something Primal in the human
mind and it signals to the audience that
they're watching something special
it's also an absolute pain in the butt
from a permitting safety and Equipment
standpoint because it can be such a
challenge to do in a legally legitimate
fashion a whole lot of uses for fire
have been confined to either remote
events out in the woods that are
difficult to make it to or
professionally run events that have the
capital to make navigating all those
hurdles cost effective but both of these
Solutions effectively mean that fire
isn't available all that often to the
general public partially because of this
there was also a bit of an inflection
point Circa 2012 wherein there was a
move towards making fire a subset of
performance types available to flow
artists and having daytime or LED props
rise to prominence as our primary
performance mediums and personally I
think that this is a good thing overall
it means lots more flow where the
general public can see it and without
the physical constraints of fire we
wound up producing a lot more Innovative
new tricks but it also took away one of
our big hooks to the general public like
part of the problem here is that fire
kind of became a crutch and without it a
lot of what people were doing just did
not look as impressive for a lot of the
POI vocabulary out there right now the
average person doesn't know the
difference between somebody starting out
and somebody who does Super Advanced
Tech because to them all they can see is
a person standing there awkwardly while
balls on strings been around them and
it's not super inspiring Beyond
encountering flow for the first time and
wanting to get into it there's also the
question of how to begin learning it
flow arts in general and especially POI
exist in kind of this uncanny valley of
appearing easy enough to learn but still
having a steep enough learning curve
that it turns some people off a whole
lot of people who watch you spin out in
public or at a club will wind up asking
if they can pick up your prop for a few
minutes because to them what you're
doing looks simple enough
then they quickly find out it's not
really as easy as they hoped and they
get discouraged things like Dance Yoga
and parkour all have relatively low
barriers to entry because you're
fundamentally only using your body and
the environment around you with POI and
flow Arts you have to learn how to move
an external prop that does not want to
move like the human body at all legit I
think that this is one of the reasons
why the past decade has seen a rise in
popularity of flow Arts that use static
instead of flexible props as well as
Gateway props that are easy to make look
cool with almost zero effort like Levy
wand Dragon staff and fiber whips but
that's a topic for another time so that
just leaves churn that is keeping people
in the art and this is something that we
have a spectacularly bad track record of
it's really common to see people enter
and go hard in the scene for a few short
years and then disappear never to be
seen again and that's fine people take
up hobbies and drop them all the time
but for a lot of other sports and
pastimes that do go mainstream people at
least continue to make an effort to stay
plugged into the scene even if they're
not actively a part of it people who
picked up skateboarding and then moved
on to other things still watched its
debut in the Olympics and cheered on the
athletes people who danced as kids and
then fell out of the Habit as adults
still watched So You Think You Can Dance
on TV to the best of my knowledge this
does not happen when people exit the POI
and flow art scene when they're done
they're done done and they don't pop
back in to see what people are up to
we'll get more into this when we talk
about the cultural reasons why I think
POI and flow Arts never hit mainstream
but suffice it to say I think that a lot
of people quit specifically because of
the scene itself and has to be said we
really do not make it easy to stay in
the scene as casual practitioners the
events are far off in remote locations
that are deeply unfriendly to people who
don't enjoy camping or have kids and we
don't really make staying in touch with
the scene online terribly accessible
either if if you wanted to find out who
were the movers and shakers and the POI
scene right now where would you even go
to ask alright so now let's talk about
what I think is the real elephant in the
room and that's the culture around the
flow Arts this without a doubt is the
biggest reason that I don't think we
went mainstream because a lot of people
doing it straight up didn't want us to a
lot of people coming into the flow Arts
were coming from a place where they felt
like weirdos out of touch with the rest
of the world part of the reason the
remote events were so popular was that
it was like getting to immerse ourselves
into a little imaginary world for a
weekend it makes us feel special when we
find other weirdos like ourselves and
more than a few of us were coming from
other scenes that are more mainstream
and having POI or flow Arts break out
also meant something kind of threatening
to our sense of uniqueness or safety the
same thing happens every time a new
music genre hits the pop charts all of a
sudden the people you hated in high
school are now listening to the same
music and showing up at the same
concerts
these were supposed to be safe spaces to
hang out with other weirdos how dare
they
this winds up leading to a lot of
gatekeeping and aggressive rejection of
anything that could make the culture
more accessible to the mainstream and
flow Arts has gone hard on this some of
the biggest stars of online flow Arts
are people who've deliberately packaged
themselves in ways that are abrasive to
middle class sensibilities whether it be
in mode of dress or the content that
they produce and let's be real there is
no shortage of other Pursuits that have
gone mainstream that are associated with
Rebellion again snowboarding and
skateboarding both come to mind but in
both of those cases they're packaged in
a way that is just edgy enough to appeal
to kids that are trying to form their
identities and just accessible enough
that their parents won't completely
freak out about it but spinning fire in
the woods with a bunch of hippies who
haven't showered in a week on drugs
yeah little Bobby is not going to get
the permission slip for that trip and I
honestly truly think that this is kind
of a shame I enjoy flow Arts not because
it's an extension of a counterculture
identity but because it's a great form
of Fitness an incredible Gateway into
understanding Math and Science and an
awesome way to meet new friends it's
brought a lot of joy into my life that
has nothing to do with the scene around
it and I think that a lot of people out
there could benefit from it and it also
has to be said flow culture has a strong
aversion to the idea of competition and
that is something that hinders us
because without signifiers of people to
watch or pay attention to it creates the
impression for people watching from the
outside that we have no superlative
artists we're all just unskilled
hobbyists now that might seem ideal to
many of you out there who dislike the
idea of hierarchies or find the idea of
celebrity or stardom abhorrent and
valid position to have
but also realize that a lot of people
like to enter into a new thing with a
rough idea of where they can go with it
and what are the things that they can
accomplish through it if there is no
concept of progression or a clear route
to getting there it becomes just another
way for people to dismiss us all as
having no achievements okay so I've
outlined a few of the many reasons that
things plateaued so the question is
can they ever build steam again and go
mainstream honestly I think the answer
is yes learning a prop may require a
steep learning curve from a beginner but
that hasn't stopped skateboarding and
snowboarding from becoming a big deal
either and both of them had kind of a
strange and somewhat inaccessible
subculture associated with them first
too they still all broke Through
Skateboarding very legendarily is a
cyclical business and I suspect flow
Arts might be no different so what would
need to change for us to do it so first
and foremost I think we have to be
willing to accept that bringing new
people into the flow Arts can be a good
thing as the flow festivals slowly die
off because of a lack of new people
coming in and buying tickets the ability
to appeal to new people isn't just a
Nifty idea but also kind of an
imperative if we want the culture to
survive in any form at all that means
being open inviting and accepting as
well as encouraging new people to
explore this world and become a part of
it the gatekeeping has to stop and quite
frankly I think we need to clean
ourselves up a little bit we need new
generations of flow artists that can
appeal not just to people who've already
drunk the counterculture Kool-Aid but
also dress and present themselves
normally enough that they don't
automatically turn off anybody who isn't
already singing with the choir and as
bitter a pill as it is to swallow I
think we need to have ways that we can
identify people who are making big
contributions to the flow Arts the POI
top 10 list kind of filled some aspects
of this role for many years
but I think a project like that can't
just be the product of one person's
Channel it has to be something with
Community buy-in and really reflect
Community Values in a way that better
achieves consensus and yes I think
competitions would not be a bad thing
for us but how do you judge the flow
Arts well I mean how do you judge
yo-yoing how do you judge parkour how do
you judge Kendama it's not like there
aren't other creative skill toys that
have figured this out before us we just
have to be open to absorbing the lessons
from them but more fundamentally than
that I think we need to hold ourselves
with pride not superiority but pride
pride is something that has room for
humility and welcomeness superiority is
the false belief that as flow artists we
are somehow more enlightened Noble or
pure than the rest of the world and that
is neither true nor helpful we have to
think that what we do is cool and worth
sharing with other people we have to
embrace not just a wide range of
participants but also people watching
and absorbing what we do from the
sidelines they're just as important and
we have to give them something to grab
onto we have to present a version of
ourselves that captivates the interest
of the general public and insert it into
places where it's going to be seen But
above all else we have to want it I
certainly do how about you so that was a
lot and there's a lot here that I could
have covered but didn't what are your
thoughts why why haven't the flowers
gone mainstream leave me a comment and
let me know it takes a lot of support to
make a video and a channel like this
possible so I'd like to single out some
folks who've stepped up to make that
happen first up the friends of the
channel dark monk fire Mecca flow fests
flow toys juggling calling pyro Terra
light toys spin balls and Ultra POI to
learn more about what all these awesome
companies are doing to support flow
artists like yourself check out the
links that I have down in the
description I also want to shout out my
wonderful flow patrons for supporting
this video and the channel without their
support none of this would be possible I
have a patreon so if you'd like to sign
up to support my work go check that out
over at patreon.com drexfactor POI and
if you dug this video and would like to
see more of my videos on Flow Arts
culture and economics I'm going to leave
a link to a playlist down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you want to check that out for
yourself thanks so much for watching and
make sure to get out and flow today I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace